Ah
ah ah Final Fantasy 4 points application All 8 Before it was announced It's the latest work of
the Final Fantasy series released on August 27th this summer after waiting for more than 3 years
.
It's
a game that shares the world with thousands of players in the genre, so it's a
game that you can only see the fun when a lot of high quality characters are displayed on the screen, so
this time the hard specs are still  Playstation 4 Since it is quite up, the
character chair that can be displayed at the same time and
the height of each character's empty space is that I think that the 8 specs of ps 4
can be fully used.  The
hardware specs are overwhelmingly different, so it's a big game experience.
Then, even those who have been watching with the ps 3 version, after all
, when you look at the screen of ps 2 4th, you can immediately see the difference that is one bullet.
I think that thanks will change.
FINAL FANTASY 4 Tin Shinsei Rosen is compatible with remote play.
This time, in mmo rpg, not only battles but also things
called gatherer crafters, for example,
are collected from the field.
And then, by creating things in a class called production crafter
and playing quests alone, the level goes up,
so I'm thinking of doing it today
or depending on the play I'm thinking of doing at this time  I want to play in a relaxed car environment.
I really want to continue today. I think that the
number of choices will increase
,
and I think that the mmo rpg will definitely play on that pc
.
I think that it will be an advantage over other mmo rpg in providing things to console players this time, so this
time it has that touch, so after all the target is  In other
words, when it comes to where and what you want to access on the
screen, you can use it as a mouse-like role while actually holding the controller and where
you want to point on the screen.
I think that it will be one big thing and even more in the controller play, I think that the barrier with the pc version will disappear or
it will go in a good direction.
I'm glad that you made it, so I think that you can connect a lot of devices, so if you
want to play with a mouse keyboard,
and if you want to use a more gaming interface,
various choices will expand at once.  In that sense, that's what I mentioned earlier,
including the remote play, but I feel that it's not in the hardware that has the most choices.
I think
it's a place where players can tell the fun of the game on behalf of us by sharing the videos they played in the world today,
and in fact
, the announcement of ps 4  I've been doing this for a long time, and this time around FINAL FANTASY 4t, there
is a bell with that voice over voice, but
I'm trying to make sure that there are no rights-related issues with the cooperation of everyone in the voice actor industry.
That's why I think that being able to capture content while watching the movements and play, not just chatting
, will be a different way of playing, so I
definitely want you to do that.  I've made it so far, so
I'd like to fully support its functions as much as possible.
This time, the Final Fantasy Forty Eight application all the is
very casual and quite story-like with an emphasis on the royal road of ff.  It's a
game, so I'd like you to start playing with confidence at all, and first of all
, I would like you to take a new adventure journey to become a player of light in the world that breaks the new olds.